so the question is when should you use machine learning
think of using machine learning
when the condition of your application changes often time
when you think that it is complicated to handle it programmatically
by yourself in fact
when you need to update the condition of your program here and there
just to meet the expectation
this is where machine learning shines
and whenever you find yourself in a very complex environment
this is also where machine learning shine
when you're not really certain about things that needs to be done well
you can deploy machine learning
and while all these things may sound just like theoretical
one thing I would advise you to do
is research more on some of these things
every time I come to you with some of these tips
what is required of you is to find a way to do further research
to have clear understanding of what you need to do
at every point in time my question to you right now is
what is that project that you're gonna use machine learning to build
and this is what we're gonna be looking at in the next episode
we're gonna be looking at a couple of projects that we can build
and not just that
we'll also find a way to build it with modern artificial intelligence
around us right now
so follow me on all my social media platform and like
comment and ask me question and I'm here to answer you right away
thank you so much and I'll see you in the next one